what's up everybody welcome to LED live
today we're going to be talking about
the movie ugly dolls what is the movie
ugly dolls really teaching us about find
out on this episode of LED live thank
you guys so much for your support you
can support this channel on patreon if
you'd like and it's a great way to get
some little perks you can get some
behind the scenes footage you actually
get early access to everything we put on
YouTube you can also support us through
buying our DVD these are not actually
available on YouTube but they're
available on digital download on Vimeo
you can actually buy the physical format
on our website
that's little light Studios TV and you
can buy cool shirts like these and wear
your witness and it's a great way to
support us as well so let's get into the
ugly truth about ugly dolls so this
movie like a lot of movies that we see
they have this parallel universe like
this two different worlds and two
different types of people this
separation you know it's kind of like
this heaven hell type scenarios what it
looks like we'll check out this clip
right here millions of dollars are
created perfectly designed to bring joy
to people everywhere but what happens to
the doll
who are so perfect I believe the world
is real I'm starting to wonder with no
evidence no proof what if it's not true
find your own truth Wow
IG has notice about that clip I mean
that last sentence is interesting find
your own truth like that's just a motto
for today isn't it yeah very postmodern
did you notice the the two different
worlds she's like talking about the big
world I want to go to the big world but
I'm starting to have doubts like is it
really even true you know there's no
proof and so that that's kind of like a
I see a parallel between Christianity
because you know yes we read about it we
have this hope that there is this you
know afterlife that we can live forever
in happiness and whatever like that so
yeah seeing this character you know
describing hey you know there's this lay
on that we can all go to that you know
someday everything will be perfect
yeah and doesn't she sound excited about
it you know there in this place ugly
Ville and she sounds like wow there's
this mystical place the big world that
she wants to go to so they're on a
journey to try and find how do we get to
this big world that we've heard about
they actually find how to get there but
see we see these parallels you can look
at the difference in the perfect world
and ugly Ville what are some like just
things that you notice that are
different about them everything's super
orderly mmm-hmm ones very bright and
colourful very drab and gray mmm you
have this kind of like huge door opening
up to in what looks like the clouds you
can't quite see where it's going and
it's like kind of you know mystical
light so decide splash is a Institute of
perfection with these giant gates
opening up and a bright light coming in
and they're just an all looking at it
I mean very seems like they're really
trying to make it look like this is
heaven you know
so look what does this say you know ugly
dolls there this is their slogan that's
actually at the end of their trailer
perfection can stuff it so I can tell
you right now they're gonna fight
against anything that's perfect and it's
it's gonna be the same kind of thing
that we've seen pumped out of Hollywood
for so many different movies now it's
like literally hitting at the you know
you're broken and there's something
wrong with you but celebrate it anyway
and you know I mean like don't don't
don't try to fix it which actually is
ironically you know it sounds good on
the surface right because it sounds like
if all we're trying to do is run around
and be perfect and we're masking all
these other things then then we're lying
basically and that's the angle I'm sure
they're gonna take it's the same as the
lego movie ya know the lego movie opens
up everything's in perfect working order
and there's a song it's called
everything is awesome right which
typically we use the word awesome kind
of a lot more loosely if you look at the
definition you know something it's more
along the lines of something that
inspires awe it's right it's it's it's
something you would describe God as like
God is full of alright and at the end of
the movie after they throw out the book
of instructions after perfection is gone
after all of that then they play the
song again so they're reassociate
against the rules
the absence of perfection chaos it's a
reassociation at the end so it's it's
very very gnostic and if you look at our
world today we're very much you know
there's like this this everybody
realizes how imperfect we are you know
as human beings and what do we do with
that you've got one of two choices you
you embrace the fact I'll never be
perfect I'll never I'll never be what's
right or the other alternative is you
can embrace
Christ and his perfection that's right
there's no like confusion about what
this is saying perfection can stuff it
right yeah and you know this means right
yeah I did I did a definition search
just to show you stuff it said to
express indifference resignation or
rejection so you know this is not a
positive message and here you can see it
they use it all the time and their
slogan but here's another clip let's
watch this bad hair day
Lester ugly little hearts freely judge
no problem did you notice any key words
in there like when it showed the guy
yeah when she when when when she said
feeling judged yeah feeling he said
bless their ugly little hearts or
whatever that's like feeling judged and
he was the one that was poking I'm like
no not good enough right right so I can
tell you like they're setting this up
already that I'm sure the bad guys is a
representation of heaven and you know
they're gonna unroll this idea that you
know this is the bad thing because
they're just like gonna just judge you
for you know everything that you are and
you just need to let your freak flag fly
yeah and it's like you know embrace that
brokenness where you know I the Bible
doesn't say anything about doing that
you know I mean it says give our
brokenness to God and let him heal us
what's interesting to me is this is
always targeted if little kids yeah it's
the same way like frozen right she says
in the lyrics that perfect girl is it
going yeah and she says no right no
wrong no rules for me I'm free freedom
is in no rules yeah freedom is you know
it's just like the oligo movie it's it's
and these are all cartoons they're all
aimed at little kids and you look at
that and I look at that and I say you
know the devil is trying to lay a
foundation with the very young and that
is if I can if I can get rid of the idea
of rules right from the very beginning
I've got yeah
you know then the rest of their life is
gonna be completely messed up the
Antichrist spirit is described as
lawlessness and if he can get rid of the
rules then he can make everybody lawless
and it says the sin is the transgression
of the law and sin is bondage so freedom
is that law of Liberty that the Bible
talks about and that's in the New
Testament we're not talking about some
like yeah and the Bible says be
therefore perfect even as your father in
heaven is perfect
right it doesn't say do it in our own
strength no but it says be perfect so
this is going completely against a
biblical concept
basically it's saying whatever that
versus what verse is that you know I'd
have to look it up so that verse can
stuff it I mean basically you can
replace their message with that you know
so let's see so this is this is the guy
so this is Liu okay we're gonna take a
look at him look how he's portrayed you
know the spotlight is on on these names
yeah he's like perfect blond hair blue
eyes the spotlight so he's paying
attention to it's all about him think
about it what in the universe what is it
all about talk about God yes all about
Jesus right I mean literally he's the
one that it's all about so this is
interesting yeah
that's where he feels perfect one here
to the Institute of perfection where
only the best will meet their perfect
human match do you honestly think your
little band of sock puppets stands a
chance here it's probably better if you
just go back where you belong
are we really not good enough for the
big world no our flaws make us unique
those are all worth fighting for
oh you do know that Lou is gonna make it
super hard for you well I say bring it
on Louis
[Music]
plus their ugly little hearts
did you notice anything there Michelle
what'd you notice yeah like for example
he they call Alou was like the perfect
one yeah like his everybody look up to
him everything he does is always perfect
whatever he does is perfect
yeah and he may be doing something bad
but they they still gonna call him
perfect so it's like he's perceived to
be perfect but then you kind of see a
little window yeah he's like insensitive
Judge this ugly dolls right and he's
literally like you know like challenging
one of those little ugly dolls like you
know oh yeah you think you're gonna
gonna be in this you know that's
interesting the first song that they
play that you catch the lyrics the
chorus line is it it it's either it
couldn't be better than this or it
doesn't get better than this okay right
see ideas perfection no no no that's not
the best yeah it's wherever we're at our
flaws is what's best you know in that
you can't get any better than that which
which sets up the idea especially in a
little kids - like well why would I want
heaven why would I want perfection why
would I want this especially if it looks
like the way they portray yeah yeah
better to be just messed up all the song
list I almost included the song listing
but like you said can't get better than
this this one's called unbreakable
your mom has forces what does it mean to
break a horse and like make it submit to
train it yeah like I'm unbreakable you
can't break me that's rebellious yeah
that's what it is that's true and in the
song you heard her say open up their
eyes as we see this again like in their
land I can open your eyes the serpent
said eat this fruit your eyes will be
open see you bring all the languages
there you bring up a good point because
the music they were actually promoting
this is like you know this has got all
this amazing energy in it no these
artists in it and a lot of people don't
really pay attention to the words of the
music but they know the artist is in
there so they're like oh yeah this is
cool my my favorite artist is like
singing in here or something like this
right so they'll go see that see that
cartoon because their favorite artist
has music in
but those pieces of music are powerful
they'll stick with you they'll stick
with you and and and little kids
remember those little tunes and jingles
I mean my daughter she literally heard a
pop song like a normal pop song and I
think she literally heard it once and
and in the main chorus phrase and she I
hear her walking around the house and
humming this ridiculous song and I was
like where did you get that she's like
oh you know I heard it it auntie's and
of course right but once that's all it
took once and it stuck in my daughter's
mind so these songs got stuck in my head
just putting this together but I wish I
could go back and watch this again and
do a checklist there's so many little
things in there she said do you really
think we could be perfect you do you
really think we can get to the big road
or whatever are we good enough so many
little things like that and then she's
like we're pretty lovable and he's like
oh you're so ugly like what does the
Bible say about how God judges man and
how he views every single person like
they are so you know invaluable to him
yeah well man judges on the outward
that's very conscious so he's saying
you're ugly and she's saying we're
lovable so we are ugly essentially in
God's eyes and we're attached to sin sin
is ugly sin is wicked and so our hearts
without the transformation of Christ are
ugly mm you know they're black the Bible
says it you know talks about in Jeremiah
17:9 it says the says the heart is
deceitful above all else and desperately
wicked who can know it so more than
anything else in this world your heart
will lie to you yeah and it's wicked so
it's just drawn to do evil things so God
looks at our heart says yep
you got a black heart because of sin
it's an ugly heart now if you come to me
here's a new heart and they don't
replace it but you don't see that count
of redemptive personality or yeah it is
interesting that they're using something
truthful yeah but it's almost like the
insinuation of it they're only showing
you a part of it it's
innovation of it is the evil you know
what I mean because it's like it's like
if if this main character is a
representation of God or Jesus or
whatever and he's running around going
you know you are you are evil inside
right I mean we know that no man is good
only God right now and so that that's
truthful but the way that they pinyin is
is it's like they they almost pin it
from sort of the Saints perspective it's
a bad thing to be transformed yeah yeah
because this movie could have said wow
were these ugly dolls and there's this
perfect place and there's this guy that
can help us get there but they are
remedy yeah and he does and he throws
him the washing machine does all this
and they're just like this is horrible I
don't even want him to go through all
this this is what it takes this makes it
makes it like look like
being perfect it's hard it's impossible
to be perfect yeah so let's just stay
the way we are no more than impossible
undesirable yeah do you even want it
yeah you know that's no matter what the
process is you're rejecting it from the
get-go yeah let's see what I got next on
you oh okay so this is the words from
her own mouth listen how she describes
Lou who we've just been looking at this
is how she's on the set so we're not
it's not our words it's hers
Lou is the leader of the Institute of
perfection he's like the president there
he's a god to them they worship Him they
love him they live their whole lives to
like impress him and they think that he
is going to be in control of their
destiny and he will be the one that gets
them to their proper home and their
proper child and everything will be
perfect
and Lou has the key to making their
lives perfect and Mandy sees right
through him you know I think that she is
a little brainwashed by Lou a few times
but you know she sees through him and
she doesn't like how he treats the ugly
dolls she thinks he's a bully and she
actually thinks he's pretty obnoxious
Wow so so it doesn't it's a Jesus with
bees did that yeah I mean that's what
she's doing with the key right oh
there's so many little keys I found
languages Harold's right there I mean
you know and and even that people
worship Him and that he's going to bring
them to this greater life yeah
there is no eternal life outside of
Jesus he is the way the truth and the
life I mean we cannot make it to the
Father or this other life without going
to the door of Jesus so here's an
interesting concept just to just I pull
up my phone so I can get the reference
it says this psalm 19:7 the law of the
Lord is do you know what it says it's
perfect right reviving the soul some
translations say converting the soul the
testimony of the Lord is sure making
wise this simple and God comes to us and
he says you know you need a new heart
and what is he gonna do on that new
heart he's gonna write his law which is
what it's perfect perfect so we're in
rejecting this idea of perfection we're
rejecting what God wants to give to us
yeah right the parent Eden
we're perfect because think about it
like this what if what if just
hypothetically we're like let's
celebrate our brokenness right I don't
want your perfect life and Jesus comes
Oh just kidding okay now I want your
perfect life like you know what I mean
like now is the test now is the time
that we should be preparing ourselves
for for eternal life not just waiting
for that magical pill translation
experience so you go back to that Eden
Eden
you know scenario everything there is
perfect the people are perfect
everything is about as is absolute
perfection because God did it he did it
right it gets ruined and then humanity
spends the rest of its time until Jesus
comes doing what
rejecting the idea that we would have
bunneh be restored to that like what is
heaven all about it's about Eden
restored yeah
right not eaten rejected mmm so to put
this idea again into a child's mind I
think it's a very dangerous thing you
know then they go to Sunday school or
Sabbath school or wherever they're going
and that you know they're talking about
this perfect place and everything the
kids gone I don't know that I want to go
to yeah place you know I want to be Who
I am I want to be colorful I want to be
happy you know this sounds terrible
perfect places are a drag it's
interesting that you brought that up
about eating restored because when you
see the end of this movie yeah you'll
see the twist of that okay and what you
said just blew my mind about how Jesus
is the door to God because clearly Lou
is the Christ type figure people go
there to be to like get this perfect
character and then they get to go
through this portal that's it puts them
into the big world that isn't the big
world so they have to go through Lou to
get to the big we have to go through the
Institute of perfection he's right
yeah I mean it's like dead-on so here's
some more about this character how she
feels about you know she is perfect she
lives in perfect vellore Institute of
perfect perfection and this is how she
feels about Lou so are you really here
just to train for the big world you bet
and we're all gonna end up with our own
special kid to love you do know that Lou
is gonna make it super hard right well I
say bring it on Louis he means well of
course though he can be a big judge and
you think still without his constructive
criticism none of us would ever get
anywhere so just stay on his good side
mm-hmm
he's a bit judgmental yeah if you don't
his new judge yeah you're going to be
you know cast out reprimanded zapped
whatever he's somebody you should listen
to yeah she even said his corrective
criticism is is a helpful thing none of
us would be here without it yeah
and so she hits the door here and you
see that these glasses pop out of her
pocket and they find out oh oh well at
first they just start trying them on and
she's like looking offended or whatever
and they're like oh we're sorry and
she's like don't tell Lou I'm not really
perfect if I was perfect I wouldn't have
to wear these glasses and so I mean it's
just like it's so twisted because the
movie is veiled in this story of
acceptance of people who might be
different but look who they are I mean
these things look like demons or
something I mean they're monsters the
one little guy with the like kind of
like spiked teeth and he's got like kind
of bat wings he looks like a little
devil yeah I want it this is where Lou
does a song called the ugly truth this
is such a parallel to the small foot
thing that you did when the stone keeper
was talking about a beautiful lie or
whatever the a good lie you know this is
exactly the same plot with a Lear
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want someone love you baby gotta
look like me
I'll be flawless built perfection upper
shelves Wow
ahh so many biblical language there if
you want perfection you got to look like
me yeah I mean what is Jesus really
asking us to do mmm
be like the father like him right but
you see what's interesting to me is is
the devil is just counterfeiting what
God is doing right so he wants us to
look like him and and the devil throwing
all these accusations against God you're
just cruel you're just insensitive you
just make people do these things to you
you ask him to do something that's
impossible right you're making do this
all this isn't possible but what's
really interesting is it's really the
devil that is actually doing all of
those things he's he's literally
two-faced and you know it's like he's
trying to portray that he's this angel
of light to people or this good guy and
yet he's he's pointing the finger at God
and saying you know he's the real evil
I'm the one that will help you so
another interesting verse here
send Zephaniah 3:17 says the Lord your
God is in your midst a mighty one who
will save he will rejoice over you with
gladness he will quiet you with his love
he will exalt over you with loud singing
right to Christ sings over it's about
his people over his people to his people
right and here we have see this
character he's singing to its people
can you imagine seriously when Jesus
sings in heaven loving people I can't
imagine I mean everybody's this gonna be
like let me hear ya we hear some
people's voice or just like wow it's
amazing
here's the guy that created voices
here's the kind of created everything
you know so some of the things he said
you haven't got a prayer he's throwing
these words out there what was the other
one do you want to earn your way to the
big place or whatever he's putting all
the stuff out there what I think is
interesting
look at his image how many of him are
there
he is like a Trinity here triple yeah
and it you know of course we were gonna
say it's just a video background but it
would continue on forever we only see
three I mean I nothing is done by
accident in these movies right so that
and that it's like even like you know
one that's super prominent one that's
kind of like you know ghostly and one
that's like you can't quite make them
out and then he says some more stuff
right here
[Music]
what gotta measure up to or you get
eternal bliss look the whole movie is
talking about
we're toys that want to find a kid to be
with if you've ever watched Toy Story
you know that kid outgrows you and you
become a dusty toy on the shelf or go to
the yard sale why is he talking about
eternal bliss right that is just
purposely showing you who he is and what
he's here to offer right right
I mean dude this is just in your face of
course we're not covering all of it but
when you see the template and if you
were to ever to sit down and watch this
movie I bet you just you could just
write lists about everything that you
see in this movie so here is when he's
talking about he's revealing his dark
side what this ugly truth is about
because that song we just heard was
called the ugly truth so listen what he
says here find out everything you can
about their town and report back to me
tomorrow night night like a days no but
there is one more thing I need you to do
ugly dolls I'll crush them or destroy
their dreamer to save my perfect Empire
nothing is too extreme I know how to do
it
well now look into uncouth a plan that's
so foul gross nasty they'll never see
[Music]
the idea that they're making that
there's some sort of ugliness about the
truth and when I hear truth and you know
you constantly associate truth and then
you associate there's something evil or
malicious behind it mm-hmm I mean that's
that's just planting these little seeds
in kids as minds and you wonder why they
grow up and they're Gnostic either/or or
agnostic or they're atheist or whatever
they're just like whatever I don't wanna
believe with God I don't know so just
like earlier we said perfection can
stuff it and Keith brought up the verse
about what is what was it about
perfection is it God's the law yeah well
there was the law of the Lord and then
there's the the other one that says be
therefore perfect your mother in heaven
is perfect
what's what's really disturbing about
this last piece is you know God is going
to destroy all that is ugly no he really
is to preserve his King and to make him
look evil yeah just like this guy said
you know to I'll do anything to protect
this he and I using his exact words of
an environment my kingdom my whatever it
is he's like I have to do this to
protect you know this place you saw a
narcissistic he was paintings and
sculptures of himself
yeah and so it's just really twisting
the idea of God and what he's really
going to do at the end and just setting
people against that completely yeah so
with a song title like ugly truth I
thought we should bring up this verse
John 14:6 jesus saith unto him I am the
way the truth and the life no man cometh
unto me
no man cometh unto the father but by me
I mean this song literally saying that
the ugly truth is Christ you know and
and the one who's going to destroy the
ugly dolls and all of them to protect
his empire I mean it's just like this is
so in-your-face
how do we not see this yeah if you look
at the Jewish sacrificial system they
required a lamb you know or a dove or
you know it depending on you know a
little bit on your financial situation
and what the exact offering was and all
that but but typically we think of a
lamb right and and so when John says you
know behold the lamb of God who comes to
your take away the sins of the world
everybody knows exactly what he's
talking about this is sacrificial lamb
and so that lamb it couldn't just be any
lamp it had to be without spot or
wrinkle in other words it well not
wrinkle but it had to be without spot
right it would be perfect couldn't have
any blemish that's the word I was
looking for without spot or blemish it
had to be absolutely perfect there could
be nothing about it
because it was a picture of Jesus so
it's a perfect sacrifice it's a
representation of a perfect God that
would lay his life down why because of
all of our imperfections so to to you
know offer up this idea that you know
what just just keep being imperfect the
way that you are is really a slap in the
face to Jesus who came and that was his
his whole purpose was to die for all of
our imperfections so to get rid of that
I mean you're getting rid of the idea of
a savior why do you need God at all
right so yeah and like I was saying you
know God is judging the heart and this
they make this guy look like he's not
letting you in because of all these
physical flaws and like you said the
blemish she goes up to a girl he goes oh
you got that blemish on your double chin
and as
in on it I mean dude this thing is just
full of these parallels yeah this is how
this is the final battle and this is
right before the happy ending but the
monsters the demons if you will battle
against Jesus or Lu here and just listen
to what they're accusing him of and what
they're revealing the truth about him
it was don'ts don't need you your
training you did it all just to feel
what's happened to you we were like
brothers yeah you a reject we're gonna
leave me just like the others ever
wonder why the pretties turned on you it
was you you tried to have me recycled
you wanted to leave so bad I sent you
right where you belong was I should've
waited to make sure you blur recycle
[Applause]
[Music]
good dog
girls girls are you gonna let them take
over after everything I've done for you
so where do you want him boss
hmm I haven't decided any suggestions
[Music]
Wow I I can't remember what how are you
I need to see the beginning again did
you guys catch some of the stuff at the
beginning oh he was saying he basically
was he basically saying in the very
beginning that he he this whole
Institute is alive we don't even have to
have this institute to go to the big
world that's what you're saying and they
find out that this whole thing has been
this ugly truth lie thing and then
holding everybody back yeah being able
to go through the portal yes interesting
there's some kind of dialogue and
argument between him and the green
character there and it was like you know
he is indicating that he had gotten rid
of him like he had cast him out right he
did um I think in the storyline that
green character was actually his friend
and at one point in time and then he
ended up so he was a perfect guy
probably perfect know as a little green
guy was it was an actual mistake and he
made it through like I think there's a
machine that makes them stamps them out
it shows you kind of in the beginning of
it yeah and and for some reason he just
accidentally made it through this
machine or whatever for whatever reason
and he was an anomaly or whatever and
then he became his friend and then he
basically turned his back on him and
kicked him out and banished him to that
world where the ugly ugly dolls live I
guess that I gave in to what you want
exactly that's kind of where I was going
with that it's like it's like casting
Satan out you know yeah he didn't belong
in heaven yeah and they were friends you
know Lucifer was close with God very
close and then I don't know this might
be a stretch but right here it's it's
kind of like you know everybody's
turning on him like they did with Jesus
crucify him you know and then the the
girl she was like so what do you want us
to do with them
now the boss is the ugly doll chick look
how they end this thing so Keith brought
up that we're going to that crisis going
to restore Eden and everything is going
to be perfect
but look how this movie ends
[Music]
[Applause]
they merge the two worlds together the
portals permanently open between heaven
and hell basically so did you notice how
like when they merge the two and they
said they're gonna merge the two that
it's actually really like they're all
defaulting to the lowest common
denominator the the ugly ones didn't
then all of a sudden to actually learn
to be perfect it was like the yeah the
perfect ones defaulted down to trick
everybody down with them an embrace to
their singing about like where we're
misfits and all this stuff you know that
that was what they embraced it's
interesting the use of color you know
the contrast between the two worlds it's
you know great things that are gray are
considered to be cleanly are considered
to be boring they're considered to be
drab right things that are very colorful
it's it's like brightness is associated
with cheerfulness and Happiness but
there's another aspect I look at that
and I see you know I see this in film
you look at Pleasantville
you know it was a grey world
black-and-white you know everybody knew
where they stood and then when sin
started coming into the world
then they started seeing the color yeah
right that's why the Apple turned red
that's why people's lips turned red
that's my shirt started getting color
and dresses started getting colors
because of sin here you have these you
know sinful creatures they're the ones
bringing in all the color if you look at
even our language if I just if I
describe something to you as oh that's
colorful language yeah that's not a good
context yeah right right yeah and I'm
not saying there's me there's nothing
wrong with color God invented color
right I'm just talking about from the
the aspect of film and what things mean
you know artists use this all the time
they use specific colors to attach
meaning to the storyline you know so red
has a certain meaning and blue has a
certain they're supposed to invoke
emotion
and all these different things so that's
why they use it in advertising yeah
exactly that's why food is always a red
and yellow
McDonagh yes guys parties parties all
those like there's a reason why those
color schemes are the way that they are
and what I also found that was very
interesting the devil does such a good
job at making drinking poison look good
yeah I mean it's literally like
mastermind it's it's literally like you
can celebrate this like dysfunctional
ugly pile of dirt that is full of pain
and misery but we're gonna make it look
desirable no he did in that Garden of
Eden with the fruit right Yeah right
you know I mean and trading that you
know beautiful existence over over
something like that I mean eternity
that's what the devil is a mastermind at
and he's flipping this whole story
around I mean this is this is a classic
example of how this is pretty hard to
deny ya can't look at it necessarily
because you you see it so many times I
mean like we brought up a lego movie at
the end of that movie he convinced the
god figure was his name Lord business
too to get rid of the rules and they
were like you know break everything and
build everything the way you want it and
that's what you see going on here the
same with small foot at the end of that
movie the the stone keeper was like
throwing the law off throwing the stones
off of his body I don't know exactly how
that movie ended I'm sure there was a
merger between the Yeti world and the
human world or something there's always
actually what world
yeah small foot series and and yeah
that's interesting you know because I'm
starting to think about Revelation 20
right when you've got that city of
Jerusalem coming down Revelation 20
verse 7 and and Satan is loosed out of
his his prison for a thousand years
what's happening the city's coming down
world's be righteous where are they
inside the city right the dead in in
their sins are
all raised up and everything right and
they're sitting there going like let's
blend this thing or let's take it or
let's do whatever make it our own
let's not battle against the wicked
let's let's bring heaven to earth and
let's all live together right and it
looks insensitive if it's like what he
wants to destroy us and end our
existence and you think of the Avengers
movie all of those like they all
literally are a pattern of the same mold
so I just want to bring out again from
the Bible some of these interesting
phrases that when we look at the idea of
perfection this second chronicles 25 and
this isn't the only place you can find
this says Amaziah was 25 years old when
he began to reign and he reigned twenty
and nine years in Jerusalem and his
mother's name was Joe Howe Adhan of
Jerusalem and he did that which was
right in the sight of the Lord but not
with a perfect heart right what did God
want from him he wanted him to have a
perfect heart so even though he was he
was starting to go the right way his
heart wasn't completely perfect with the
Lord right and if you look all
throughout the Bible you see this says
in 1st chronicles 29 19 I on the solomon
my son a perfect heart and then it says
to keep thy commandments like
testimonies and thy statutes and to do
all these things and to build the palace
for the which i have made provision you
know it's another instance like I gave
Solomon a perfect heart and it was for a
reason right it was so that he would
walk in my law and we already seen write
the law of the Lord is perfect right
converting the soul so you can see this
over and over again this idea of
perfection and in the Bible first Kings
861 says well let your heart be perfect
with the Lord our God to walk it in his
statutes and to keep his Commandments as
it is this day over and over again you
see the idea of having a perfect art so
to reject the idea of perfection is to
reject God
so these movies when you're sitting your
kid down in front of it and they say
perfection can stuff it you know the
ugly truth
my imperfections are something to be
celebrated I mean that is straight
brainwashing propaganda satanic and it's
just mind-blowing that we are living in
a world where we have to like have so
much discernment to analyze a kid's
movie right yeah but you know it used to
be just cartoons right but then when you
look back over the cartoons even from
this mindset the more you study the
Bible the more you kind of understand
spiritual things it's saying you can go
back and look at those old cartoons and
you'd like man that was messed up like
there was they've been working on this
for so long
probably since the television was
invented yeah you know I mean it just it
just breeds this kind of personality and
and and the reason I really think that
this is even possible I don't know you
know this is a pretty crazy parallel I
think like it would be hard for me to
say the director does not know yeah what
the truth is because he's making so many
you know decisions creatively that
really are are too close to the truth
maybe he got it in a dream you know he
could be used by the devil doesn't know
it so on this merger of both worlds
found this first Matthew 13:49 it says
so shall I be at the end of the world
the Angels shall come forth and sever
the wicked from among the just there's
not going to be a joining of God's
people and the lost I mean that's
I'm just hairs are separated from the
wheat yeah that's very clear they're
making this movie look like this is a
good thing and I understand I mean it's
every comment we're gonna get is you
missed the point they're trying to say
don't make fun of people everybody's
special I believe that I get that I
think that this is a subliminal
storyline woven into what could be a
good movie but why do you have to make
this guy have all these parallels to
Jesus Christ why do you have to make
this a two separate worlds thing where
you're in the ugly
and you're trying to get to perfect
ville and you merge the two you can make
a movie without having all these
parallels I thought it was interesting
the the actors were asked the question
would you rather be an ugly doll or
would you rather be a perfect doll be an
ugly doll or a perfect dog you know I
play perfect doll in a movie honestly I
think I'd rather be an ugly doll it
seems like a lot more fun I agree ugly
is where it's at Wow I mean it just
tells right there it's like that's the
motive that you're gonna walk away
exactly you ever seen anything from
Disney's TV show and movies descendants
oh yeah
same exact thing yeah they take all
these evil characters and they make them
cool and hip and they're the ones you
want to imitate emulate all that and
they're the underdog they're the others
oh I'll get first and you have all these
kids that wind up wanting to be like
them you know yeah and it's it's a
terrible thing but it's interesting
because you know another movie Suicide
Squad same kind of thing anti-heroes
right they're bad guys but they're there
to save the day in that interview if you
look at the one that it was done with
Will Smith and all those guys you're
like yeah we wouldn't really you know
want our kids you know to model after
this or something like that you know
it's just crazy they recognize it but
here when it's and it's wrapped up in a
kid-friendly package yeah people try to
say it's not it's not targeted to kids
it might not be but I sure merchandise
stuff to kids the Legos and all that
stuff you know Suicide Squad so I want
to go back to this idea that Scottie
said earlier and kind of tying these two
ideas that you had and he had together
he was talking about the poison you know
the drop of poison and you know you put
the drop of poison in the cup the cup is
still a poison cup people will take
something like this and say you know
you're missing the point there's there's
this other message at the end of the day
if you mix error and truth yeah it's
still air it's not truth yeah you know
it's not the truth yeah and so you you
you want to draw truth out of it
but once that poison has been mixed into
the cup you got to go to great lengths
ugly tree about then and and and Christ
what he really wants to do is he wants
to separate you know he wants to extract
that that poison out of the cup so that
it's just what's left in the cup yeah
it's not supposed to be in there he
wants to take all of that out of us all
of our imperfections out of us and leave
us with what we were meant to be what we
were made to be mm-hmm and so to take it
together and say yeah you know we just
we just we just want you know this part
and it's fine
it's not fine yeah you know you can't
mix truth in error you guys like pumpkin
pie yeah well he was like punk you love
it yeah if I really love it okay okay
but literally if I made a pumpkin pie
and I put 1/8 of a teaspoon of human
waste in the pumpkin pie would you eat
it no way which part is it pumpkin pie I
mean it like tastes like pumpkin pie you
wouldn't even taste it you wouldn't even
taste it yeah but if you sat down on the
table and you knew hey there is some
human waste some garbage in here yeah we
would all be like no way no way you
couldn't pay me money to do that right
we pay there was to do that with the
things of God
we we all want to when I want to take
these kind of messages where good and
bad are coupled and say yeah I just I
just I just want that part over there
you know what I want to oftentimes take
the the watermelon approach you know
I'll eat the good parts and instead of
but we're messed up and Christ is really
the only one that can do that can make
that separation right yeah and so we
need to be very careful what we take in
because we may see some of this we may
not you know you may not agree with some
of it you know it's a bit but there's a
good message at the heart of it yeah
right but see Satan is never gonna send
you here here's a bowl of poison yeah
look like poison it's gonna look like
someone skinned pie with a huge thing of
whipped cream on the top exactly what I
mean and it's like you you you have to
consider I know we hear this all the
time all the time people yeah but you
know what there are really good things
well of course the devil is not gonna
serve you straight error he's gonna mix
it in truth at the end of time that's
one of the core issues that's where all
worries that's why we're always can art
being about people about studying your
Bible and making sure you know your
Bible because at the end of time it will
be in a differentiation of do you want
the truth or do you want the error mixed
with the truth because it's all gonna
sound good it's all gonna sound right
it's all gonna sound very biblical
mm-hmm but people are gonna be deceived
and Jesus says if we don't have a love
for the truth that we're gonna get a
strong delusion and we will believe the
lie okay so that's why the truth is so
important yes God honestly how many
parents are actually watching all these
with their kids they're usually sitting
them down in front of it and expecting
the kid to be able to have the
discernment that uh maybe we adults
might have but but they don't and and if
we have a documentary that covers this
but just very briefly the reason they
don't there's actually a medical reason
that they don't and that is when kids
are young they have neurons right there
that are firing in their mind there's a
couple of class of neurons you can focus
you can focus on the motor neurons which
are involved in movement they're also
involved in something else but there's
also mirror neurons so when you tell
kids do as I do as I do not as I say
right is this never works oh you never
works
never works because they're
biochemically good wired for it to not
work whatever you made not as I do yeah
yeah yeah you say do as I say not as I
do right yeah they're always gonna do
what you do yeah
always because they're biochemically
wired at a young age to do what they
seaton it hmm now where the motor
neurons come in is those are also the
neurons involved in judgment making
so making those moral decisions these
aren't developed yet not to their full
capacity
so the little kid doesn't know what do I
do
in this situation they have to grow into
that and as those neurons develop then
they can get that but it takes training
and it takes development it takes time
it's not right out of the gate doesn't
happen right that's why as a parent
you're responsible for that child early
on to guide them and show them and walk
them in a way because they don't know
and they're not yet capable of making
those decisions there's no there's like
medical reasons even behind that you
know that's like God set these
safeguards in place you don't have a
baby
leading the parent you have a parent
leading the baby right and a young child
until they're old enough to make those
decisions but until they understand
that's right
mmm very powerful you know that was that
was excellent Keith you hit the nail
right on the head and you know I hope
you guys as viewers you get a chance to
you know think about what you're
allowing in front of your children's
minds especially if you're you're
Christian and you're wanting to raise
them with Christian values these little
cartoons will combat plant little seeds
they put opposite messages into your
children's minds and you know when they
grow up to be teenagers and they leave
the church and everybody's thrown their
hands in the air going why why is my kid
leaving the church you know you look
back on their life and perhaps they've
filled their minds full of these kind of
things so you know be cautious be
careful with what you allow into your
mind we've got tons of documentaries on
our website that that go more into depth
in this subject check out some of our
other videos if you're new here thank
you for coming and watching our video
and hit that subscribe button of the
Bell and you'll get notified if we put
new videos out so thank you so much for
watching we'll catch you guys next week
on LED live bye guys
[Music]